okay welcome back to the last session
uh taking things off we have steven
schramm who's the professor at stanford
and before that was in cambridge and
before that was here uh talk about
computational barriers destination from
low degree polynomials
thanks
all right this is i think this is my
first
in-person talk
since before the pandemic so i'm like a
little bit nervous actually standing up
here but
it's a sea of friendly faces
covered by masks so we should be good
okay
um all right so the title of this talk
is computational barriers to estimation
from low degree polynomials and this is
based on joint work with the wonderful
alex wine
and the setting of this talk is uh
trying to understand the computational
complexity of planted problems so
studying
we basically have
we're given a input which consists of a
signal
perturbed by noise
so to make this more concrete let's
focus on a specific family of models
spiked
gaussian matrix models
so here i have a distribution p lambda
and
a sample from p lambda has the following
form it's a n by n matrix x
which is given by a rank 1 spike
plus iid noise
so
the law is that
every entry of z
is independent gaussian
and every entry of v is sampled
independently from some prior mu
okay so depending on this prior you can
kind of capture different uh scenarios
that you want for example
uh if if mu is some sparse prior
like
bernoulli
a over n
then this is some kind of version of
sparse principle components analysis
uh and the idea is that you know you
have a bunch of uh
a matrix of data and you want to
understand how things are correlated and
there's some sparse subset of
coordinates that are positively
correlated
um okay so here we this is called the
planted submatrix
problem
but by changing this prior you can
capture all kinds of different uh
scenarios um and okay the idea is that
this is a simple
yet pretty faithful model of problems
that we encounter in statistics like
principle components analysis uh
problems
okay
so
there are two natural algorithmic goals
that we might associate with a planted
problem like this so algorithmic goals
so the first
is uh estimation
or recovery
okay so here given
x sampled from p lambda
the goal is to find v
okay the second goal which is so this is
kind of like a search problem
uh there's also a natural kind of
decision variant of this problem
or testing so testing or
detection
so here we're given x which is sampled
either from
p lambda
or
p0
and the goal is to decide which one
so actually this uh at this point i
realized that i forgot to say something
that's kind of important right so here
we have this lambda sitting in front of
the strength one spike so this is like
the signal-to-noise ratio
which i'll abbreviate snr
and as lambda gets larger and larger the
problem should become easier and easier
to solve because you have more and more
weight on the
uh planted vector do you want to recover
okay and here uh
if x is sampled from p let p zero right
that's like no signal noise ratio
meaning it's just pure noise okay so so
in the detection or testing problem we
want to decide if there's any planted
vector at all right so this is like the
decision
version of this search problem
all right so
the title of this workshop is rigorous
evidence for information computation
gaps so it shouldn't surprise you that
for this problem there are information
computation gaps
okay so i spent
a really long time as i was preparing
this talk
trying to figure out what the phase
diagram should look like so i very
proudly present to you what i'm what
i've confirmed with guy bressler is a
correct phase diagram
okay so let's say that i'm in this
planted submatrix problem
and i'm going to parameterize it as
follows i'm going to let k
be like
n to the alpha meaning the vector has
n to the alpha non-zero entries on
average and i'm going to set lambda
equal to n to the beta
minus alpha
okay and here
i'll let alpha range from zero to one
and i'll let beta also range from zero
to one
this makes it a unit vector or something
yeah beta is how much i'm promoting it
above being a unit vector
so the minus alpha is like me yeah
exactly okay so this is what the phase
diagram looks like
so
in this region
both goals
estimation and testing are easy
in this region
both are information theoretically
impossible
and these three triangles things get
pretty spicy so
um okay so in this region both are
conjectured hard
and
in this region
testing
is easy
but
recovery
is impossible
and in this region testing is easy
but recovery is conjectured hard
okay so
we have a pretty uh
interesting landscape here um oh yeah
apologies in advance for not so i
thought about how to cite this in a
board talk like there are at least 15
papers that are responsible for each of
these various lines so in lieu of citing
these which we do cited in the paper but
uh live instead if you've worked on this
phase diagram please raise your hand
[Laughter]
come on guy
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]
yeah right props to yeah i think i
started jamming earlier but
anyway okay if you've worked on this i
applaud you greatly thank you for
for your service and your site you are
excited in our paper which is on
archives probably on zoom watching to
see how i'm tracing his hand in his
office very good
um okay cool so so this is what we this
is what we have and what we want to do
is we want to offer okay so you can see
that you know in the regime where things
are
okay so so in the easy regime uh we have
proof that it's easy because
were you going to say something again
oh sorry okay all right so in the easy
regime we know things are easy because
we have efficient algorithms right in
the information theoretically impossible
regimes
we know information theoretic
impossibility because you know you prove
some uh bound on the total variation
distance between the two destinations or
something like that
but for the hard regimes we don't really
have um
the same kind of concrete evidence but
we do have some evidence right so the
whole the whole goal of the of this
workshop is to provide evidence for
computational complexity
okay and
so let me
lay out a little bit of evidence for
hardness that we have
okay so
okay so first for the testing problem
meaning uh that this that this little
triangle here is hard so for this we
have a variety of different
lower bounds against uh restricted
models of computation but we also have
reduction so evidence based on reduction
so
um we know
that
based on a reduction
from planted clique
that this regime should be hard for
testing
okay and then here i was going to cite
uh
15 and
brennan wrestler and cool
okay so this is i think this is pretty
good evidence for computational
attractive blood if you believe that
planet clique is
uh hard then you also believe that
yeah
uh what does planet click hard mean like
what's the special you're using here
uh i i
believe that for every
region in this point you have a
different uh
planted clique hard point that maps to
it
so
but i think i think square if you
believe that square root n is the
um you know upper bound
then this whole region is uh
substantiated
okay all right cool
okay but now for recovery uh our
evidence for hardness
has so far not been has strong so
for uh recovery slash estimation
so for recovery and estimation there are
reductions
but uh the reductions are
uh like i think each of them leaves
something to be desired right so there
are also reductions from planted clique
so
i'm sorry it's not from planet league
from uh
densest k-sub-graph or a
plant-case-planted k-sub-graph so this
is also in this work but here you have
to assume that there's a detection
recovery gap in the problem that you
start with in order to get a detection
recovery gap here and there we don't
have a strong evidence for um detection
recovery gap either
so that's one thing there's another
reduction that's due to
uh
kai liang and rocklin from 17. but here
they end up with a slightly more
complicated um noise distribution in the
output so it's not it's not strictly
speaking for gaussian noise
[Music]
okay and then there are a couple of uh
algorithm or lower bounds against
restricted models of computation so
lower bounds
against
uh mcmc
and also
amp
but the problem with these lower bounds
is that mcn mcmc and amp are known to
sometimes
be uh beat by other algorithms like for
example for tensor problems so if you
have that uh these
models don't work that's not necessarily
the strongest evidence that no algorithm
can work
soon i see raising here yeah um so with
this
case sub graph thing this problem is
just like the gaussian version yeah
right so so this is just
some reason to believe that you
shouldn't care about the noise
distribution
well i think i mean i guess like you
know you can maybe even think of a zener
i mean guy probably knows better but
maybe you know the universality like
results for the noise distribution but
um but you do need i mean you do need to
assume that that is harder
yeah
inside the clique is kind of like that
okay i don't know
okay so so that's uh
that's uh what we had so far and then
our main result
is a lower bound
against
low degree polynomials
so let me just circle this
so this is this is kind of our main
result we get lower bounds against low
degree polynomials that show that the
testing or the recovery problem is hard
even in this regime
where the testing problem is easy
okay in fact
uh we get a
so what we're doing is we're
substantiating this uh
detection recovery gap over here
and
um
and okay and uh one thing about the low
degree polynomial
model is that
it does seem to be consistent as far as
we know with the thresholds for
efficient computation for other
algorithms so even though this is only a
lower bound against a restricted model
of computation we do get an
unconditional lower bound against a
model of computation that seems to
capture
you know it seems to be tied with the
best algorithms that we know so far
okay so that's kind of the
the
high level
uh picture and now in order to tell you
more precise results i need to
uh give you more background but i think
i only have do i really only have five
minutes left no that [ __ ] is fast you
have nine nine minutes left okay great
okay so uh here's a little bit of
background maybe
maybe i'll erase all this stuff
okay so here's some background
okay so the following
is a quantity
which is supposed to measure
how well polynomials of degree d can
hypothesis test between the planted and
null distributions between p lambda and
p 0.
so
l d i'm going to define this to be the
max
over all polynomials
in the input of degree at most d
we take the expectation
under the planted distribution minus the
expectation
under the null distribution divided by
square root
the variance
under null
all right so
notice that if this value is of order
one
then there's no polynomial whose value
can give a hypothesis test which
succeeds with high probability
like with a guarantee given by a
chebychev's inequality or something
right because the variance
uh overwhelms the
difference in the means
so
if
ld
is it most order one
no degree
polynomial
can hypothesis test
uh and another cool thing about this
quantity is that actually it has a nice
closed form
right so
the closed form for this is i just take
the likelihood ratio
of the two distributions
i subtract one i project the span of
polynomials of degree at most z
again i take this uh
norm in the p zero basis so if you don't
know what this means don't worry about
it if you know this means
you can like it this is kind of like
taking the chi-squared distance and
projecting to functions of degree d
so
i mean if you want to take the value of
it actually i don't mean thresholds of
polynomials what i mean is if you want
to take the value of a polynomial so
here this is saying that the difference
in the expectations is overwhelmed by
the variance yes by the standard
deviation under the null distribution so
this is this is precisely what i mean
i think intuitively it should mean that
no threshold this
literally all distinguishes that i think
is probably formally possible but like
but this this doesn't establish it right
yeah like that's what i'm saying you
know you could i don't know for all you
know you put the parity of
i think even with thresholds you can
sort of play this uh trick right like
you can make like weird delta functions
showing a percent i mean i'm not sure
but you know it needs some work to
formalize it but i really i guess i mean
i do i mean they can't hypothesis in the
sense that if you look at its value
and you ask that it falls above some
range
um probably this won't work okay
yeah well again but okay yeah i don't i
don't literally want to claim anything
about threshold i just mean that this
like this type of guarantee won't work
yeah
okay so uh here is a conjecture
which uh let's attribute it to sam
hopkins
in 2018.
so the conductor is that
for
any nice
kind of problem
a degree
so okay if l poly log n
is order one
no polynomial time algorithm
okay so this this conjecture it might
seem very strong right it's it's sort of
saying that
uh the this this quantity
has the power to capture
all polynomial time algorithms as long
as you take the degree to be logarithmic
in the size of the input but so far this
conductor stands if you at least if you
allow you know some
uh class of nice but for example the
nice class contains all additive
gaussian models
um and many more and uh like this so far
yields consistent conjecture for um
the sub matrix for tensor principal
defense analysis sparse principal
pronouns analysis planetary
stochastic block models
you know many and many others um
great
but okay if you look at this this is
really tailored to say something about
hypothesis testing right i mean we're
really asking about the difference
between
uh plan then p0 so what should you do
for estimation
so that's that's really what the subject
of our paper is
and then for estimation
we study the following quantity which i
think is is fairly natural so it's the
mmsc
then
a minimum mean squared error of degree d
so this uh i'll define it as the minimum
over all polynomials
must be an input
of the expectation
under the planted distribution
the square difference between the
polynomial and let's say the first entry
of u right so by symmetry
the first entry of v will capture
everything
okay so this is the degree d minimum
mean squared error it's asking how well
can a function of degree at most z
estimate the first coordinate of our
pointed vector
and this is a very natural quantity but
it's very unclear how to bound it there
is no
similar closed form
i thought i had more time i thought i
wouldn't take as much time to get here
sam's telling me i have two minutes so
let me just cut to the chase uh
immediately so okay so the theorem
can you see if i write down here okay so
theorem
[Laughter]
so uh in
this red region
uh the
degree
uh
polylog n
mse
or a planted submatrix
is like k over n
minus k over n squared
minus little one
which is exactly what just
using the function
uh f of x is equal to the expectation of
v1 would give you up to this little one
factor so
in other words we're showing that no
polynomial of degree at most poly log n
can achieve non-trivial estimation in
this whole red region
or like when does it form yeah it's very
small like even if you allow
degree
n to the epsilon
still this is a little o one
um but i didn't i didn't want to like
you know i mean yeah i don't want to
write the whole parameter trade off
because just like little over 1 means k
little of k over n squared or something
yeah okay smaller than all the other
terms yeah
okay great uh let me also just say that
you know this our i stated the theorem
for um
planted sub matrix but actually we get a
characterization or some kind of upper
bound on the mmsc at degree d for any
any additive gaussian model in any
binding observation model and we have an
analogous theorem for the planted dense
subgraph problem or the density subgraph
problem um substantiating the difficulty
of recovery
in the region where there's a detection
recovery gap
um
yeah so lambda
i was kind of hiding i mean it's here
right but i'm just so this this uh whole
map
encodes that so like you know lambda is
fixed by beta and alpha
so for any lambda flying in this kind of
slice yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um
yeah great so so that's that's the
result i guess i i had planned to tell
you a little bit about the proof but i
guess i don't i don't have time but i'm
happy to talk about it later um let me
just say that i think the open
directions
are ample because even though we were
able to say something non-trivial for
any additive gaussian or planted
or sorry binary channel model
you know there are many many other
models that aren't covered by this
result where we still don't really know
how to
substantiate computational
interactability when there's a detection
recovery gap so my favorite problem is
over complete tensor decomposition
if you have ideas please come talk to me
yeah and thanks so much for your
attention
yeah
yeah so uh first off i recommend
everyone look at this paper
they're in the rear edit last night
a specific question here about your
prior and
um there's something interesting with
the prior so if you have something
that's symmetric with plus one minus one
then uh there's no rejection
right so imagine you can get from your
results some
understanding of like what what exactly
sort of the amount of asymmetry in the
provider
yeah
i think that if you wanted to encode it
if you wanted to do a different prior
but you want to out of gaussian
situation um
we have some upper bound on the
degree d minimum mean squared error
and it's just a matter of calculate i
mean it's just it's some calculation
like it it's a calculation that's maybe
not that dissimilar from the
like usual low degree likelihood ratio
calculation one that you have to do is
like when you diverge
yeah yeah totally yeah that's totally on
the table yeah
so is it what's the detection algorithm
is it being easy immediate algorithm
yeah you just take the sum of the
entries of the matrix
and sorry in the regime where there's a
gap yeah
yeah so easy yeah
so since the typical detection threshold
doesn't work how can you give an idea of
like what what do you change for
recovery
like uh
yeah so it turns out that this quantity
is actually fairly different than the
other
because you're not looking you're not
sort of comparing
instead of constraining the
variance of f
under null to be small
you're constraining the variance of f
under this planted prior to be small and
that's a much stricter
restriction
and that's sort of what makes the value
smaller
and it's more challenging to carry out
the calculations because of this but we
were able to overcome this in a way
that's like still fairly magical to me
and i don't really have intuition for
why
it worked
oh sorry tim yeah is this the same uh
minimization
[Music]
the thing is is that the variance
is bounded under null instead of
underplanted
and for black models that's
that's a small enough distinction that
it doesn't make a difference but here
where there's a detection recovery gap
there is a difference and were you to
use that things would turn out
differently right
yeah you wouldn't get anything
yeah
i mean maybe it's a small enough
difference in block model but it doesn't
make a difference in the thresholds you
get but it's still the case that the one
that we did doesn't make any sense
like
it's just cooked up so that we can prove
something
um okay other questions for sleep
okay thank you